horror movies always provided a certain
kind of thrill that comes out of the
suspense that I thrive on
who doesn't love Silence of the Lambs
Anthony Hopkins I mean if he does the
chianti move would it still creep you
out today I think so that well I just
creeped myself out my favorite scary
movie is strangers and that is the only
scary movie that I will ever watch with
her first time I saw The Exorcist was in
a drive-in theater and I was really
fascinated more than scary when I watch
a scary movie I have the lights on first
and I have to close my eyes when I want
cuz then she'll be like no opener like
it's not fair I know you don't see those
scary faces it's just not the same
everything I learned in life I learned
from ghosts but it's a movie that is
kind of a fantasy but you want it to be
real sorry Becca we wouldn't want to be
in the bowels of the New York Public
Library on Fifth Avenue and have the
Dewey Decimal System attacked it is very
much like a roller coaster ride
I love the tension the adrenaline rush I
ended up having a huge crush on Linda
Blair I mean that was one of the early
year war that they got in your head and
would not like
a really great score becomes as much of
a character in the movie as the actual
physical human beings because I think
that's what makes a great horror movie
is the stuff that you don't see hi my
name is willie Geist
Mel Roca I'm slash Manny and I say and
we love movies really good
you